I want you to pause this
video and figure out
if you can figure out the area
of this quadrilateral right
over here.
And I'll give you a hint.
Try to break it up into
shapes where it is easier
to find the area, especially
given the grid of these unit
squares that we have
right over here.
So I assume you gave it a go.
Now let's try to do it together.
So I'm going to
start at points where
it would be very easy to measure
the dimensions of whatever
figures we might break it up at.
And so in general,
I want to go to any
of the whole numbers
of these units,
so that point right over there.
And let's see.
I could start to move
in this direction.
And it looks like I might
be able to construct
a triangle down here.
And it would be tempting
to go all the way across,
but that wouldn't be
too useful because this
gets me to halfway
through a unit.
And I'm just eyeballing it to
say halfway through a unit.
It might not be exactly
halfway through a unit.
And so instead, let me
see if I can get away
with making a triangle
just like that.
Now, I just did that.
So let me try to
raise this up to see
if I can make another
triangle where it would
be easy to figure
out its dimensions.
So once again, I don't
want to go all the way
up here because now I'm
not at a whole unit.
Instead, let me take a right
and go right over here.
And notice, both
of these are very
easy to figure out
its dimensions.
This is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
units long and 1 unit high.
This one right over here
is 1, 2, 3, 4 units long
and 1, 2 units wide.
So let's see if we can cover
the entire quadrilateral,
if we can break it up, I should
say, into a bunch of figures
like this.
So it seems like we have
another one just like that.
And then I could drop this
down, and then we're done.
All of these are pretty
straightforward to figure out
what their dimensions are.
This is 5 by 1.
This is 4 by 2.
This is 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6 by 1, 2.
And this is 1 by 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So what is the area
of this figure?
And of course, we have
this center rectangle right
over here.
Well, a triangle that is 5 units
long and 1 unit high, its area
is going to be 1/2
times 1 times 5.
Or I could write it
1/2 times 1 times
5, depending on what
multiplication symbol
you are more comfortable with.
Well that's just going
to be 1/2 times 5, which
is going to be equal to 2.5.
So that's 2.5 right over there.
This one is going to
be 1/2 times 4 times 2.
Well, that's just going
to be 2 times 2 or 4.
This one is going to be 1/2
times 2 times 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Well, 1/2 half times 2
is 1 times 6 is just 6.
And then this one's
going to be 1/2 times
1 times 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So once again, the area of
this one is going to be 2.5.
And then finally, this
is a 3 by 4 rectangle.
And you could even count
the unit squares in here.
But it has 12 of
those unit square,
so it has an area of 12.
So if we want to find the total
area, we just add all of these
together.
So 2.5 plus 2.5 is 5, plus 4 is
9, plus 6 is 15, plus 12 is 27.
So it has a total area of 27.